[Music]
new Terror charges against an Ottawa
teenager this Monday night the
accusations he was plotting an attack
against the Jewish Community deepening
Despair and Desperation in Gaza what is
happening in Gaza should make all of us
outraged and why Christmas is cancelled
in Bethlehem I never seen in my life be
like that danger in the Red Sea who's
attacking cargo ships and the effect on
the supply
chain plus Alberta's oil and gas sector
thirsty for water we've been on a a dry
Trend the consequences of a drought on
the
Prairies global national with Donna FZ
good evening and thanks for joining us
an Ottawa teenager charged with
terrorism offenses was back in court
today to face more charges including
possession of an explosive device the
suspect who cannot be identified because
of his age is accused of an alleged plot
to Target Jewish people Jewish and
Muslim communities are concerned hate
motivated crime is on the rise driven by
the Israel Hamas War globals McKenzie
gray was in court today for this latest
hearing
McKenzie yeah Donna the Ottawa youth
that was first charged this weekend with
alleged terrorism offenses was back in
court today where Federal prosecutors
leveled three additional serious charges
the minor who cannot be named due to his
age is now facing a possession of an
explosive substance charge and another
charge alleging they intended to use the
explosive the RCMP has said the minor
was allegedly plotting an attack against
the Jewish Community the third new
charge is an additional count of
facilitating terrorist activity the same
offense they were first charged with on
Saturday along with allegations they
instructed others to carry out a
terrorist activity Global News was at
the Ottawa courthouse for today's
proceedings which is covered by a public
ation ban so we're unable to report
other details the father of the accused
was also in the courtroom and he spoke
exclusively with global news about his
child's arrest on Saturday and I warned
him many time he me and his mother uh
stay away from you know extremist or
something uh and we his mom arranged
some sessions with the Imam you know we
never had this in in the family after
that interview Global News found a
Facebook page of a user whose name and
photo match the Father which had several
derogatory posts about Jews and Israelis
the publication ban does not allow us to
show them but one of them says to get
rid of all Israelis asked to confirm if
the Facebook page was his the youth's
father said his lawyer had advised him
not to talk to reporters and the posts
were subsequently taken down these are
very serious crimes that they're being
charged with terrorism experts concerned
not only about the Ottawa case but about
four other youth recently arrested and
Calgary also on terrorism charges I
think it is the fact that uh they spend
so much of their time online that helps
us to account for the fact that more and
more youth are being drawn in the Ottawa
youth is set to return to court on
Wednesday Donna but until then they will
remain in police custody okay McKenzie
gray in Ottawa tonight thanks the
pressure on Israel to change its
strategy in Gaza is mounting as is the
death toll there close to 20,000 people
in Gaza have now been killed since
October 7th 70% of them are women and
children that's according to the Hamas
run Health Ministry today The American
Secretary of Defense arrived in Israel
with a blunt message yes Israel has the
right to defend itself he said but
civilians need to be protected he didn't
call on Israel to stop but said
operations must be at a lower intensity
and more surgical outside that meeting
families of those held hostage in Gaza
pleaded they not be forgotten Crystal
ganing on the pressure the Israeli
government is under
and how it's
responding their voices aren't as
piercing as in days past but they're
using every breath to demand the return
of their captured loved ones it's this
man US Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
whose attention they want it's critical
as I said earlier that H Hamas not be
able to threaten
Israel from
Gaza or even threaten Gaza anymore you
know that's an interest that we all
share Austin made no demands of Israel
at least not publicly the retired
fourstar General did call on America's
longtime friend to protect civilian
lives during its operations inside Gaza
a reminder of the rules of War stated
multiple times
before late Sunday Panic inside a
maternity and children's facility
attached to Nasser Hospital in Han Yunis
footage from inside the hospital after
the incident showed smoke bloody
children and a hole in a wall along with
scattered debris Israel is conducting
operations in the area but it's not
known who was responsible a doctor at
the site says a girl was killed by a
shell that hit the facility but did not
explode several others were wounded what
is happening in Gaza should make all of
us outraged in fact um and should push
all of us to rethink our values and our
Humanity Juliet Tuma tells Global News
the UN relief and work agency has had
170 sites in Gaza hit and a record
number of Staff
136 have been killed since October 7th
the level of Despair she says is Rising
by the hour what's happening is that
sometimes when we are sending trucks in
the trucks are being stopped by the
communities by people and people are
taking food Parcels opening them and
eating then and
there international calls for a
ceasefire are back before the UN
Security Council the United States
vetoed the last one Israel Defense
Forces meanwhile have now St and
released photos of white fabric with SOS
and help written in food scraps by
hostages on Friday three men were
mistakenly shot and killed by their own
soldiers Crystal ganing Global News
London BP is the latest commercial
shipping company to suspend sending
vessels along the popular route through
the Red Sea to the Suez Canal because of
attacks from houti Rebels backed by Iran
and the US says it intends to expand its
Maritime Defense Force in the Red Sea
signs as Redmond Shannon explains the
tension from the Israel Mass war is
spreading November's Brazen seizure of
the huge Galaxy Leader by Iran backed
hooti Rebels signaled a new level of
Danger on the treacherous Waters of East
Africa since then the yemen-based
militants have launched frequent rocket
and drone attacks on ships in the Red
Sea vessels they say are linked to
Israel or heading to Israel even though
some of the ship owners in insist they
have no Israeli
links us British and french navy ships
are patrolling shooting down drones even
chasing down suspected hijackers
probably a couple of months ago they
weren't alert to this threat I suspect
that the hooti new capability was as
much a surprise to the military as it as
it was to us on Monday oil giant BP
followed leading shipping companies like
Evergreen and MK suspend ending all sea
routes through the area the Red Sea
leading to the sez Canal is the key
shipping route between Asia and Europe
carrying about a tenth of global trade
the alternate route involves ships
taking a long diversion all the way
around Africa speaking to one uh one of
our associate member associations today
they've got ships on the route from Asia
and they've got to make a decision in
the next couple of days about whether
they re-root just like the blockage of
the sews Canal 2 years ago go that will
delay some goods and could increase some
consumer prices these attacks are
Reckless dangerous and they violate
international law US Secretary of State
Lloyd Austin says he will speak with
regional counterparts and others on
Tuesday to set up a task force to make
the sea Lane safe that would be in
addition to current patrols under the 39
Nation combined Maritime forces the cmf
based in Bak UK includes Canada on some
missions Austin says he will announce
more details on the task force soon
Redmond Channon Global News London
Egypt's President abdal fat L CI says
the Israel Hamas conflict is a threat to
his country's National Security he made
the remarks after winning a third term
as
president the former Army Chief won 89%
of the vote in an election with no
serious Challengers and he's expected to
hold power until 2030 when barred by the
Constitution from running a gain Egypt
is managing the impact of the conflict
in Gaza which borders the Sinai
Peninsula and struggling with an
economic crisis there are more details
about a fatal stabbing in Winnipeg this
week police say the victim was a
14-year-old indigenous girl who was
standing with three other people
believed to be known to her when one of
them suddenly turned on her I don't
believe there was a fight uh from what I
understand it was a pretty sudden turn
of events there
it happened near a busy bus stop in
downtown Winnipeg Friday afternoon
police say they're looking for a male
suspect and two young female Witnesses
who all may be under the age of 18
severe drought conditions across the
Prairies triggered a warning from
Alberta's energy regulator it may need
to restrict water to oil and gas
producers the situation in Central and
Southern Alberta is particularly dire
But the Water Crisis stretches far
beyond the West More than 70% of Canada
is experienc encing abnormally dry or
drought conditions as Heather urick West
explains the lack of moisture has
farmers and firefighters on high
alert for cattle ranchers across the
Prairies 2023 has been a dry and
difficult year and it's not over yet
we've drawn down reserves in in many
areas um it's you know we're like I said
it's been several years that we've been
on a a dry Trend much of the country is
experiencing a pre-winter drought but
the situation in Southern Alberta is
most acute the province has 51 water
shortage advisories in place at the
moment and while the impact this has on
agriculture is well understood other
Industries including Alberta's oil and
gas sector are being warned as well
industry should be proactive and plan
for water shortages during 2024 the
Alberta energy regulator said in a
bulletin to Industry last week
water is a key resource for extracting
and processing fossil fuels but across
the Prairies the precious resource is in
short supply when we look back at
previous years we've been running this
moisture deficit for quite some time now
and that's really problematic when
you're looking ahead because it's not
only just a good amount of rainfall
that's going to get us back to the soil
moisture that we need Alberta's
environment Minister says the province
is working to finalize a drought
emergency plan for the coming year
the second of an El Nino weather system
these are regular rhythmic uh Pacific
weather systems and the second year is
generally hotter and drier the Fort
McMurray fire took place also in the
second year of an alino
System since then fire seasons have
intensified 2023 was a wildfire season
unlike any other I'm not saying that
we're going to end it with the same you
know another Monumental Fire season but
it doesn't look
good a prairie drought extending into
the winter months an ominous sign
Heather urex West Global News
Calgary caving Under Pressure coming up
after weeks of earthquake activity a
volcano in Iceland finally
blows an earthquake has struck Northwest
China China State News Agency says more
than 100 people have been killed it's
reported to have been a strong shallow
Quake that caused significant damage
bringing down houses and sending people
running into the street at least 200
people have been injured and Chinese
authorities say rescue teams have been
deployed it happened in the southwest of
China's Ganso
Province after weeks of intense
earthquake activity in Iceland a volcano
Southwest of the capital has erupted it
lit up the evening sky in red orange and
yellow lava shooting into the air
Iceland's meteorological office says the
eruption started about 3 km north of
grindvik that's the fishing town that
was evacuated weeks ago because of
thousands of small earthquakes opening
multiple Fishers there were fears the
town could be swallowed up by a volcano
the size and impact of this eruption is
still being evaluated and the airport in
Iceland remains
open and nearly 60 million Americans are
under flood watches tonight along the
Atlantic coast torrential rain has
caused flash flooding in Massachusetts
Pennsylvania and New Hampshire and
strong winds knocked out power to more
than 1 million residents the same storms
battered Florida and the Carolinas over
the weekend and the severe weather
system is expected to move north into
parts of Quebec and Atlantic Canada this
evening freedom of the press ahead The
Landmark trial for a pro-democracy
activist in Hong
[Music]
Kong the United is Raising concern about
Russian opposition leader Alexi navali
the 47-year-old failed to appear in a
Russian Court nearly a week ago and did
not show up for several hearings
scheduled for today naval's legal team
says they've not had contact with him
for 13 days raising concerns the Kremlin
critic could be muzzled or even killed
he's been moved from the penal colony
where he was serving a 19-year term on
charges of extremism armed officers
stood guard outside a Hong Kong
Courthouse as the trial for
pro-democracy Advocate Jimmy lie got
underway lie ran one of the few Chinese
language Publications that supported
massive pro-democracy protests in 2019
he's accused of collusion and
endangering National Security under a
law widely seen as designed to silence
dissidents Canada is among a number of
countries calling for his release and as
Abigail Bean reports the world is
watching his
trial Jimmy lie arrives at a Hong Kong
Court the 76-year-old publisher of the
now defunct pro-democracy Apple Daily
Newspaper faces charges including
colluding with foreign forces to
endanger National Security it's a
complete show trial the security
minister recently boasted of 100%
conviction rate so an absolute CH the
case is widely viewed as a trial about
press freedom and an important marker of
the independence of Hong Kong's Judicial
System Jimmy lie is um symbolic really
of the resistance to domination from
Beijing hundreds of thousands of people
participated we could see you know from
our office Windows Jeff nanaville was
Canada's counil General to Hong Kong
during the mass protest that began in
2019 and the introduction of the
sweeping New National Security laws in
2020 because of those laws he won't say
whether he met with or knows lie and
that's simply because under the new
National Security Law uh the the act of
communicating or meeting with or
engaging with representatives of foreign
governments could make somebody liable
to
prosecution Monday Canadian
representatives were among the foreign
Presence at the courthouse call upon the
Hong Kong authorities to release Jimmy
Li last week both the House of Commons
and the Senate passed motions in his
defense but pro-democracy activist Chuck
Quan wants more action
unless there is a very very high level
and I mean the prime Minister coming out
to condemn what's happening in Hong Kong
any other action is just uh
cosmetic while Hong Kong and China are
criticizing foreign governments for
their influence China's foreign minister
called the case Justified legitimate and
lawful Li's trials expected to last
months in some of the earlier
prosecutions under the new National
Security laws he could face a life
sentence at 76 years old
Abigail ban global news Ottawa Pope
Francis ushered in a dramatic shift in
policy at the Catholic Church formerly
approving blessings for same-sex couples
the vatican's doctrine office now says
priests can offer the blessings as long
as they don't resemble regular church
marriage rituals the move is aimed at
making the Catholic Church more
inclusive Pope Francis says people
shouldn't be subjected to an exhaustive
moral analysis Catholic church doctrine
still says marriage is between a man and
a
woman next the muted Christmas
celebrations in Bethlehem as that City
Grieves for
gazin as people prepare to celebrate
Christmas the place where it all began
will have no lights or festivities
Bethlehem and the occupied West Bank is
believed to be where Jesus was born and
is usually a place of pilgrimage this
year though the deadly conflict between
Israel and Hamas has cast a shadow over
the Church of the Nativity as Danielle
Hamin discovered Christmas in Bethlehem
has been
cancelled the Church of the Nativity in
Bethlehem a sacred site for the 2 and 1
half billion Christians around the
globe and as father isaia is about to
show
us the church was built on top of a cave
where Christians believe it all began
the exact spot where Jesus was
born only one other person is here an
Armenian tourist I feel like uh I
connect with something very
important where everything
starts there would normally be thousands
of people filing in and out of this
church this time of year but look at it
now it is completely
empty we know that God's give us
strength and we continue one of the
world's oldest churches is now a
casualty of one of the longest running
conflicts this is what exactly we are
grieving we're sad for what happening so
we would like actually to pray for peace
for
love but those prayers this year will be
made in complete
silence manger square right right
outside the church is traditionally the
focal point of Christmas
celebrations but not even Co reduced it
to this due to the conflict in Gaza
Christmas festivities in Bethlehem have
been cancelled no tree no lights no
Nativity
seen the only ones you'll see are being
handcrafted in Wood
factories along with crosses and other
sculptur
only to sit on stor shelves waiting for
customers who aren't coming now there is
no one it's like a desert I never seen
in my life Bethlehem like
[Music]
that and no one has ever seen Gaza like
this around a thousand Christians live
in Gaza and this is what the only
Catholic Church in The Enclave looked
like last month over the weekend a
mother and daughter seeking shelter
there were killed Catholic officials say
they were shot by an Israeli
sniper the pope condemned the attack
calling the targeting of civilians
terrorism roughly 50,000 Christians in
the West Bank but the numbers are
shrinking rapidly my role in Bethlehem
is to keep the Christian Community in
Bethlehem as not to leave because I
don't want to turn this beautiful Church
into
museum for Ron tabash a third generation
shop owner leaving the holy land is not
an option for me I always say we have a
mission to resist to remain in this
place but we have also to think about
our children about our future the
children of
Bethlehem Danielle hamam Jin Global News
Bethlehem in the West
Bank and that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna freezen tonight's
your Canada is this Christmas tree at
the shipyards in North Vancouver BC we'd
love to see your festive Canada photos
please email them to viewers at
global.com and thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]